[Music]
my mom said when I started making
YouTube videos I'd never make it to the
Oscars she was wrong that's right we
made it to the Oscars
I think award shows are huge budgets or
fancy cameras for ten frames one second
in an advertisement during the broadcast
but still we were there I'd like to
thank Alex for our boxes and the other
people that were part of that production
I'd like to thank GoPro
mom I made it you may have noticed that
Ren is always riding a one wheel he is
absolutely convinced that a one wheel is
the best wheeled device he can put under
his feet but I think differently we just
got a halo board hoverboard in the mail
and I'm gonna challenge your end to a
performance test and if he loses it will
be prohibited from riding the one wheel
for a week
hold on we did not talk about this what
are you talking I haven't agreed to this
I challenged him to a game of ping for
those of you who don't know it's a very
simple challenge game where you imitate
your opponent's moves and set moves for
them to imitate the first person who
can't the the first proof he's already
got a P it's already got Pig the first
person to get all three letters loses
cat damn it I'm so close what you guys
doing challenge one the cones I'm gonna
go first because I'm the Challenger
which means that the burden of proof is
on me go lawyers I know I'll get there I
made it you gotta go you're shot
so now I go backwards
all right switch I didn't think about
that
the next challenge is simple it's a sex
change flip on your wheel device ready
[Applause]
is there some kumys boxes there's a
lithium ion warning so there's something
cool in here
I better open these boxes you think
that's a knife come on this is a knife
[Applause]
so we get to five sessions and to five
classes this is more wait and wait a
minute this amount on it
I have a feeling I know what this is
Christmas just changed it's now February
28th our friends at gopro know how many
GoPro videos we like to shoot thank you
so much
that is literally corridor Christmas I
have an idea sure what's actually really
cool about this thing is that it's like
all-terrain but how else rain can it be
can it handle this pothole
[Applause]
[Music]
what didn't see that coming did job god
I didn't really account for that I have
to go straight through the Bonneville
his wheels literally went around the
entire pothole I got a challenge for you
let's go off of this curve go for it
nails it alright
he's on here first Jake's gonna break an
ankle
that's up hey hey is the quarter pipe
it's pretty clever
if I lose one more time that's it that's
the game Jake you lose you can't even
touch that halo board for a week
[Music]
I'm here to talk to you guys a little
bit about this project called lifeline
that we're gonna be doing it's eight
half-hour episodes and it's going on
YouTube read on our channel which is
gonna be super cool
you can literally tell it's the biggest
project we've ever done because it's
this thick we're basically working every
single day on this right now you might
not see as much of us in the studio on
Sam and Nico videos but you're really a
lot of us on set because we are going to
be busting our butts to make this as
cool as we can make it just gonna give
you a little secret
life line is about a cool time-traveling
agent who goes around saving people's
lives just before they die seven years
ago when we started making YouTube
videos this got a project right here is
the kind of project we hoped to make
something huge something with a really
cool end of story some cool effects some
cool concepts sci-fi mumbo jumbo some
guns
we're gonna have to be shooting about
six pages a day large budget movies like
The Avengers and stuff sometimes they'll
shoot like two or three pages a day
average because they're trying to make
each shot super crazy when we shoot
YouTube videos sometimes it's like one
one and a half pages a day it's still
gonna be incredibly challenging that's
that's the biggest thing facing us right
now let's do this do three spins inside
of these without hitting
[Applause]
[Music]
I said don't hit it'd be odd for you
buddy this is for the win
don't hit him
[Music]
and finish it off for the 180 clip oh
actually a little bit impressed
[Music]
180 180 I'm sorry what does this prove
hoverboards can be just as great as a
one wheel despite what Ren's bias
opinion might say
that's not good it looks like you guys
got a brand new nice offer on halo not
you too okay so background anole
is it's the highest mountain in North
America it stands at 20,000 feet and it
is heavily glaciated it's the hardest of
the seven summits
I'm most looking forward to gay into the
top of the nollie so we have a better
chance of going to Everest next year